bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on aimerait
que fabien de société mire access qui a
développé une solution hyper
intéressante pour faire de votre
téléphone à l'ordinateur
un petit peu ça c'est ça c'est
exactement ça te considérer que son
smartphone
et l'unique pcd
d'accord et donc on a besoin
intéressé
c'est ce qu'on a créé on a créé un appel
permet d'utiliser son smartphone
pc ok alors c'est à dire le système dont
tu as ton smartphone que tu vas branché
en cours usb c'est directement sur ton
mira vous qui lui
et ensuite quand j'en suis qui va
prendre prier en fait sur un écran 13
pouces avec un clavier et trackpad
elle utilise
actuellement par exemple
sportif il qu'ils ont déjà intégré en
fait une solution qui va permettre de
faire le tri
ça va retrouver
le samsung ex1 ou comme le web est
bouilli de ce type exprime ce
et puis
on l'utilisera avec notre me rajoute
comme si c'était vraiment une extension
de son téléphone on pourra utiliser
comme pca
toutes les applications connard
mode
fenêtres
c'est une sorte de
et c'est android d'accord ça veut dire
que le marabout qui souffrait du croquis
vide avec la guinée j'imagine mon
seigneur guerrier pas rien dans mes
textes technologiquement ça fait quoi
deux ans de suite on retrouve
alors les grosses batteries déjà parce
qu'on appelle le reste vu qu'il n'ya pas
de cpu
à ta place de m
batterie on a quand même
un système unique et qui
la technologie display port
faire de la vidéo
le transfert de tout ce qui est
rechargeable
et cetera
philippe faire le
d'affaires la magie
et puis donc on a quand même une
carrière marquée mano a été développé
pour
l'ordinateur signaler c'est clair qu'il
a pas de mémoire
rajouter
on rajoute pas o'meara boucan
quand on utilise le mira bouton valider
un ultime c'est la télé poubelle
ce qui se passe sur le mur à vous qui se
passe dans le téléphone
c'est le cerveau du téléphone sur ce
rapport
ça y est
de toute la technologie toute la
puissance se trouve dans le smartphone
exact on a vu sur le comme le projet
linda de razer exactement c'est tout
nouveau et ils sont vraiment
le marché du gaming on
on est aussi compatible avec leurs
pelles et peu là
ils sont vraiment
lisez le green qu'on la regarde et on a
vu leur produit vraiment très bon poli
que j'espère que ça va continuer parce
que
ça vous le marché et
du coup c'est vraiment pas
on le voit pas comme une concurrence
mais renom comme
deux positifs récemment que vous êtes
vraiment dans la tendance dans les
allusions donc supermarché je crois que
c'est la fin en gros des ordinateurs
portables comme on les connaît
est ce que vraiment tout ce qu'on va
voir dans les années à venir ça va tous
être conscients smartphones avec
vraiment de la puissance je pense pas
que ce sera la fin du sud
reportage je pense que ça sera la fin du
mois
louez du moyenne
le ski et au dilemme ça va changer
puisque par exemple
aux utilisations au mip encore là au
niveau 2 par exemple pour faire du
photoshop ou de la 3d sur un smartphone
c'est pourquoi
prenez pour le mais pas encore la dent
par besoin d'eux
d'ordinateurs moi je fais de la 3d
justement pour bien
je vais utiliser mon arrivée
ok cool bon bah écoute super alors c'est
ce que c'est un produit qu'on peut
trouver dès à présent en fin de
développement responsable
aujourd'hui
actuellement
et puis sur notre site internet
je t d
la livre est normal
ok bon ben écoute merci beaucoup merci
et bonne continuation
j'ai mis tous les noirs description pour
aller boire je vous invite à me mettre
des commentaires pour dire ce que vous
pensez de mire un bouquet ce que vous
pensez qu'ils pensent qu'ils pourraient
vous vous intéressez par rapport à votre
smartphone et par rapport à votre
utilisation
mark et moi tout ça comme d'habitude
laissez-moi des jolies pouces
abonnez-vous parce qu'on va parler
toujours plus une entreprise française
innovante
merci très bien merci merci à toi tu vas
bientôt
[Musique]